hi welcome to the corridor cast my name
is Nico and today we are going to be
joined by Steven see mayor steve is our
landlord and you might be wondering why
the heck do we have our landlord on the
podcast well if you're not a frequent
viewer of the corridor crew channel well
you haven't met one of the most colorful
and vibrant characters that we know any
time Steve shows up in a video he steals
this show he totally takes a scene and
just he goes for days with crazy stories
just I don't know the depths of that
man's experience far exceeds any of our
own so kick back relax and let's listen
to Steve tell us about the tales of
growing up as an artist in Los Angeles
and all the crazy people he's met along
the way he's got some good stories it's
gonna be a good one
Steve thanks for being on the podcast
well thank you for having me yeah your
uh your man that probably doesn't need
any introduction to people that are
regular viewers of the coridor crew
channel but those are for those of you
out there who aren't regular viewers of
the coridor crew Channel Steve is the
owner of this building and when we moved
out to Los Angeles
we moved directly to this building and
I've never left it so I think we have a
longer a landlord-tenant history than
almost I think more people out there or
we have more of a history than most
people out there because of I know it's
just been it's been a wonderful
environment like you've created a very
unique environment for artists here and
we were very lucky to have our paths
cross with you and your philosophy as a
landlord I think is it's different than
most other people out there
you've been very supportive of the arts
you've been very supportive of us and
give me can you tell me a little bit
about that like what what was your
mission with setting up this building
like what is your ethos with trying to
you know foster this community here when
I move down to downtown Los Angeles in
December of 1976 downtown LA was kind of
like a wasteland and there weren't a lot
of artists down here and when I moved in
there was also a lot of freedom
basically if you didn't burn the
building down the fire department didn't
come around if you didn't hurt anybody
you could you could get away with a lot
of things that you can't possibly get
away with now you could just have a
party with 500 people on your rooftop
and somehow no one managed to fall off
the roof you could do a lot of things
and I always like that freedom as an
artist myself a painter and a filmmaker
I like the kind of freedom that being
downtown brought me and it was for me at
that time it was pretty cheap rent when
John Peterson who's also an artist and I
got together and we had the opportunity
to buy this building we wanted artists
that make art that make movies that make
paintings and sculpture music we wanted
those kind of people in our building
that's the lifeblood of a true arts
district and you have to have obviously
physical space but it also has to be
priced so that a person that rents a
space downtown doesn't have to have a
job where they're working that job five
days a week and they only have the
weekend two days to make art what
artists need is cheap space relatively
cheap space and they need to be able to
have time to create artwork and it is
that time it is those moments in nikko
you know this being a filmmaker that you
can sit around and throw ideas around
you can work on the development of a
script you can work on the development
of an idea and you need that time and
you can't be worrying about where am I
going to get that money to pay that
ridiculous rent nowadays a lot of
artists that live in downtown they've
got a job maybe two jobs they're trying
to make
ends meet and they don't have a lot of
time to go home and push the envelope
with their work they don't have a lot of
time to think about the work that
they're doing that work the spaces are
getting smaller and smaller and more
expensive
so whereas 20 years ago a thousand-foot
space might cost you $500 or $600 a
thousand-foot space is now three
thousand dollars for a thousand square
feet and going up so we John Peterson
and myself we wanted to be with people
like ourselves artists and people that
were creating artwork and we didn't want
to go broke either I mean we wanted to
do what we legally had to do to create a
legal artist-in-residence building and
meet the requirements that the city told
us we had to and at the same time we
weren't interested in jacking up the
rents at least I think we've achieved
that to some degree and we have artists
still living in this building that make
music that right that make videos that
make virtual reality programming and I
think we still have that what why is
that that you guys wanted to build an
artist centric building because the
entire history of interaction I've had
with you is shown that money is not the
reason you're running this building like
why is that that you have made it such a
valuable thing to yourself to make this
an artist centric building all right I
think that's important to our culture to
Los Angeles I think I think in your case
I think with Sam and Nico and corridor
digital I think I enjoyed seeing what
you guys were creating and I thought it
was so much fun to watch and I thought
this to me
is what they're doing and what other
people in this building do it's like the
forefront it's the cutting edge of
creating new imagery and I felt that's
the kind of people I want to be with
that's the kind of people I want to have
living in my building people that are
constantly thinking of new ideas and by
the way they're having a lot of fun
that's a chief prerequisite of having
some fun and doing things and you guys
do things that I've seen that it well
they're amazing and you know I thought
that's that's the kind of thing we need
we and and and not to have just people
like for example that make commercials
hmm we could have people in here that
are paying a lot more rent and and
different types of people but what's the
fun in that
I mean I'm making a lot more money but
it's it's kind of killing the culture by
doing that so you're an artist yourself
yes I think a lot of people watching
this channel some of them are familiar
with this documentary you made tales of
the American but they don't know that
your history goes back beyond that that
you're actually you're a a relatively
accomplished filmmaker you have a lot of
different projects you've done and
beyond just that you've also done like
art installation pieces some other
projects like that can you just tell me
a little bit about who you are what your
background is what your history is well
I was born in Los Angeles and born under
the Hollywood sign literally
and my background is my mother was an
artist and my father was a filmmaker and
my family goes back in the movie
industry all the way back to when Cecil
B DeMille came out to Los Angeles with
famous players-lasky and my family the
background of my family is there the
west Moors
and the westmore's they were like a
bunch of brothers the Westmore brothers
and a father George Westmore and they
headed up the makeup departments and
special effects for all of the major
studios paramount RKO MGM Fox Universal
and they were all the brothers headed up
these makeup departments like purse
Westmore was at Warner Brothers did all
the makeup for Warner Brothers for 30
years and my grandfather earned Westmore
did the makeup he won the first Oscar
for makeup on a movie best picture of
the year 1931 called
Cimarron and it was the first time they
had ever given out the Academy Award to
makeup hmm and it wasn't an Oscar either
by the way was it us it was a silver
chalice really good Cup yeah it wasn't
until later that somebody came up with
that little figure that little gold
statuette and you know Betty Davis kind
of coined the name Oscar do you still
have the chalice the family still does
oh yeah yep that's pretty cool yeah Best
Makeup 1931 for Cimarron and so I grew
up in a family that was pretty crazy
there's a book that's been out for a
number of years called the West mores of
Hollywood and they were that was truly a
crazy time the 20s the 30s and the 40s
in his town oh yeah
there's I mean I yeah I've heard a lot
of stories my mother is an artist and
she's primarily a painter and when I was
growing up we had the craziest house on
the street it would be I remember as a
kid in elementary school and in junior
high my mother would do lots of
paintings of nude women and there were
occasionally even models in our house
this actually this reminds me a story
not to go on too big of a tangent here
but a while back about two years ago we
were driving to a friend's house in
Marina del Rey and we never listened to
the radio
but for some reason we turned on the
radio to NPR and you were talking on the
radio there's more all assuming like
wait is that Steve Steve on NPR and you
were telling a story about your mother
about painting a nude figure can you
tell its story again
sure sure I was gonna get to that I was
kind of like laying some groundwork the
nude paintings in our house and my house
was the kind of place where you know
when you get out of school at 3 o'clock
in the afternoon you well I had a lot of
buddies that wanted to come over to my
house and it wasn't to eat the peanut
butter jelly sandwich it was to see all
the paintings of naked women so to me it
was no big deal but to these kids the
most exciting thing was seeing these
naked women paintings and I mean that
and a Playboy magazine and you know
you're set so back in the 60s yeah that
was a big deal for pubescent boys so
anyway and it still might be I think you
know I don't think things have changed
too much yeah so in any event in 1966 we
would go out to through Malibu Canyon
and at that time period during the
sixties when I was a kid we would surf
out at Point Dume and Malibu and we
lived in the San Fernando Valley so we
went through the valley Malibu Canyon
and we had relatives that that live at
Point Dume and at the end of the evening
at the end of a beach day my mother
would load us all up into the station
wagon and drive back through Malibu
Canyon and go through the Malibu Canyon
tunnel and she would look up and she
would see some a modicum of gang
graffiti and she would see all sorts of
stuff on the cliff above the Malibu
Canyon
and one time we even stopped there and I
had to take a leak so she found that a
very convenient place to stop and she
was looking up at the hill and little
did I know what what my mother was
planning to do but she then spent the
next six months going back there to
Malibu Canyon tunnel at night and
cleaning off the graffiti chipping it
off scraping it off with a wire brush
cleaning it off and she was preparing it
like an artist prepares a canvas hmm and
she'd never let on to me what was going
on why would you tell a 12 year old that
you're going to paint a 60-foot nude
woman you're not gonna do that he's
gonna tell the whole neighborhood so she
kept it quiet and then by the light of a
full moon on October 30th 30th or 31st
30th I think of 1966 she made a giant
stencil and hold it up to the top of the
mountain Wow and let it unfurl like a
scroll and it was a stencil with holes
in it and she then used to pounce to
make these holes a series of dots and
then she once she had the figure of the
nude woman holding up some flowers in
its hand in her inner hand she then let
the stencil go down and she then
proceeded to go back up to the mountain
and climb down and fill it in and she
painted the pink lady of Malibu Canyon
and I do remember as a kid right to make
the stencil she would have to wait for
us
myself and my brother to go to sleep
usually it was after Johnny Carson would
come on real late at night and then we'd
go to bed because we had to get up and
go to school the next day and she would
then unfurl the stencil his
huge butcher paper brown butcher paper
stencil that was 60 feet long and 40
feet wide and she would unfurl it across
the backyard and she would work on the
stencil and I remember one night late at
night getting up to get a drink of water
or something and I came out into the
living room and I looked through the
dining room and into the back yard and
there were all these clip-on lights on
stands and there she was she had fallen
asleep and was curled up with some patio
furniture asleep she was exhausted and I
walked out and I walked onto the butcher
paper stencil and there were these
enormous breasts I had had an ax and a
giant head and and and I just I looked
down at my mother and I said you know
mom what's going on what what is what is
all this and she immediately woke up and
said go back to bed go back to bed go
back I said mom I you know I gotta I
gotta have a drink of water no go back
to bed just go go and I know so I knew
something was up I just didn't know what
it was and then a couple months later is
when the painting went up and it was up
for a very short period of time this in
66 you have to understand the
environment in Los Angeles and in the
United States was very different than it
is now it was a lot more conservative I
would say now with with the current
president that we have in office I
wouldn't say it's any more crazier but
it was different it was more
conservative and in 66 you couldn't show
any pubic hair for example and my mother
I think even painted in a little bit of
pubic hair on the pink lady and they
took things very differently and one of
the commissioners not a city councilman
but
thought his name was Warren Dorn Warren
Dorn Warren Doran dor and I think he he
felt that the pink lady was pornography
he flat out came out and said this is
pornography and you know and III didn't
think it was pornography I just thought
it was a nude woman with flowers in her
hands and she's not doing a lewd gesture
she's just gambling across the face of
the cliff and anyway it was a it was a
really interesting time and it was up
for a four or five days and what
happened was the first thing the city
said was that it's going to cause a
traffic accident that people driving
through the canyon they're gonna they're
gonna stare up at it and they're gonna
look at it and they're gonna hit the
canyon wall drive off the edge of the
canyon and yet billboards are okay
yeah and and and nobody did that no
nobody drove off the canyon and it was
very interesting because the first thing
they did was they called out the fire
department and the fire department
brought out hook and ladders and big
their water cannons tried to blast the
paint off but the paint was a pink Sears
paint that soaked into the shale surface
and it actually the blast from the water
only made the paint shinier really it
was it was kind of ironic they're just
cleaning it off for you they were just
cleaning the hillside off it was great
it made the painting actually stand out
even more so there were Porter's and
news cameramen and TV news was there and
it just it just like you know it was
everywhere it was everywhere in the news
and in newspapers and in Life magazine
and just it was incredible what happened
and you know if they had the internet
now this thing would have gone viral big
time because that's kind of what it did
we have clip we have what do you called
clip books with newspaper articles from
almost every newspaper in the world that
disappeared in this story but at the
time they couldn't get it off they
couldn't figure out they tried all sorts
of things
and finally what really pissed off my
mother was that they
they said one night on a news program
and and that this this county supervisor
Warren Doran he said if if the man who
did this will come forward and let us
know what kind of paid he used so we can
remove this we won't charge him with
vandalism hmm and my mother watching
this on TV that threw a fit because
first they assumed it was a man yeah and
and that was the last straw fir
so she called her lawyer and she said
meet me out and she took me with her and
she said yeah she took me with her and
she took sketches and drawings and one
big drawing that I still have and she
and she called up the newspaper
reporters who had done some of the
stories and she said meet me out there
I'm gonna show you something
and she did and I was standing right
there when she was surrounded by news
cameras and she said I'm the one that
painted the pink lady and of course at
first most people scoffed and she said
no here's my sketches here's my drawings
my preliminary my gridded off my big
gritted off drawings to show how I did
it and she explained in detail how she
did it
and they and she said the kind of paint
she told him the kind of paint it was
and they weren't having any of it by
this time war leave her well they just
wanted it off Warren Dorn
was you know he'd just dug in his heels
and thought this was pornography so they
hired an LA County crew to come out and
also hang ropes up from the top and come
down and paint it out hmm so they got a
big airless and guys are on there and
I've got photographs of these guys
standing there on the breasts with big
shit-eating grin on their face doing a
photo op I mean I'm sure nowadays they
would have the airless in one hand and
the iPhone taking a selfie in the other
so but there was a lot of there was a
lot of action so it had a very short
life and
you know there were lawsuits back and
forth and my mother didn't have to pay
anything and the city we sued the city
for a million dollars really uh-huh
yeah what do you see the city for
defamation of a public work of art oh
and not only that when the city after
they painted the pink lady over they
went back and somebody within their
offices said oh we don't own that
property oh no we do not own the
property or the rights to it above the
tunnel so they just vandalized the whole
cliff
they buffed out a work of art that
wasn't even theirs to do oh wow so the
judge kind of went well you know he saw
the city's argument not that it was
pornography but that it could cause a
possible traffic hazard the issue of
pornography or not pornography never
came up in court it was whether it was a
traffic hazard yet they took off a work
of art that was not on their property
so both cases were dismissed hmm it's a
fascinating story what kind of
impression of your mom did that leave
you with oh well my mother was the type
of person that she was you know go out
there and do it don't ask permission and
that's probably pervaded a lot of things
I've done since I you know move became
an artist and I mean you know you just
got to do it you got to go out there and
do it as long as it's not hurting
anybody and you know I mean there's some
things that you just you have to be like
for example with this building you have
to be conscious that there's human
beings living in it and you have to be
as safety conscious as possible so I'm
not saying be reckless in that way but
in terms of being adventurous with your
art and trying to push the envelope and
trying new things
I am definitely in total agreement with
that and I think my mother for a while
was very much that way and I think she
just said your job is to go out there
and up yeah and she didn't use
those exact words but but if she were
still alive today she would use those
words hmm and she just you know she was
balls to the wall and go out there and
do it and don't tell anybody that you
can't do it you know
yes and she had people all of her life
telling her oh no you you know you can't
do this you can't do that and she would
do it so that's great I mean it's a
that's an awesome story and I would
agree with that sentiment that she's
gotta go out there and do it I mean to
me art exists to elicit a reaction
whatever that reaction may be depends on
what the artwork is intending to do but
you know artworks supposed to make you
feel something it's supposed to make you
react and it sounds like you achieve or
she achieved that with the pink lady of
Malibu yeah yeah it was it's something
when we first moved when I first moved
to downtown on the corner of Olympic in
Central Avenue it's now a parking lot I
moved into a building that was a former
brothel it was a 16 room hotel
on the second floor and it had been a
brothel up until the 1950s I feel like
every old building in LA used to be a
brothel yeah yeah and mine even had
former customers that lived in other
hotels around me and told me stories
about their experiences with the women
they used to live in my hotel which were
really fascinating
it was I I had 16 rooms of a hotel and
one room was a living room one room was
a kitchen I tore I combined two rooms
together I tore the wall up between two
rooms and made it into a projection room
with sixteen millimeter projectors and
super rate projectors and surround sound
stereo one room was an editing room
which was about the size of the room I'm
in now one room was a darkroom one room
had a table saw where I could make
frames and stretch canvases one two
rooms were storage rooms it was party
central - it was great it was really
crazy living on Olympic in central the
things I saw were unbelievable so you've
you've seen a lot of evolution of Los
Angeles and this neighborhood for that
matter the arts district you know I feel
like every time I meet you I hear news
story about what's happened here do you
have any favorites that you would like
to share with us on this on this podcast
well there's so many over a 40-year
period there are so many characters and
and quite a few of them are are not with
us anymore but one of the things I want
to give myself a shameless plug right
now because it'll back up some of the
things that I've done there are two
movies one movie is called Young Turks
and Young Turks the movie it's a
documentary and it we started shooting
it in 1977 and filmed can finished it in
1982 so I shot for five years and it
basically is about 13 artists that were
some of the first to move down to
downtown LA but one of the difference
things about this movie is is that I
decided to inter cut each interview of
the artist with an interview with a bum
and I used the term bum because that was
the vernacular at that time it wasn't
the word homeless had not entered the
vocabulary right around 83 84 people
started to use the word homeless but
before then it was a bum you're a bum
you're a wino your hobo might might have
been even a further throwback to the 60s
and 50s and 40s but so the movie has
interspersed interviews with bums that
lived in and around us and I thought
that was it was crucial to show that
they them talking and their environment
because the only difference between them
and us was a door
we didn't have a lot of money mm-hm and
so you know if you didn't hustle up some
money in some way you could be right out
there with them hmm
and it's sort of like we all had a
studio and we all knew a street person
and that Street person kind of like kind
of looked out for you and you looked out
for him it was kind of a interesting
relationship huh so that's Young Turks
and that can be seen on Amazon Prime and
then the other documentary that I just
finished is called tales of the American
and it's about the American hotel and
Al's bar and the surrounding arts
district that is changing going through
big changes due to gentrification right
now and I saw that that documentary back
when you were screening it down at the
Downtown independent theater I thought
was fantastic it was such a interesting
cue well researched like chronicle of
that neighborhood and not just that the
building but really it shed a lot of
light on the art scene in Los Angeles at
least in that section of the community
and how it evolved because I don't feel
like Los Angeles is really known as an
artist City I mean it's known as like a
filmmakers city per se and you know
perhaps a little bit photography and
music but not really in the more
traditional artist sense and I think
that's becoming you know I feel like the
art scene is stepping more and more into
the front of culture here in Los Angeles
but seeing kind of the beginnings and
the people that helps create it in the
different like philosophies and crazy
characters that were there like really
to me at least really shed a lot of
interesting light on the neighborhood
and it was the other thing I was really
impressed by was just how well
researched and documented it was you had
so many sources and so many images and I
mean you must have you worked on it for
years to put it all together I would say
from the very beginning the first time
line and the first planning to the very
last thing we did was almost five years
and we cut we interviewed oh I think we
have 490 hours of interview that's a lot
we
interviewed 149 people we used three to
five cameras that we all synched up
together and we're shooting and usually
it was three but sometimes we got a
couple extra cameras going a couple more
GoPros or some other things and so we
had a to cover a lot of people we flew
to Manhattan we flew to Connecticut we
flew and interviewed people in Tampa we
went to New Orleans and interviewed a
couple people we went up to Oakland so
we went the distance to reach people
that had lived in the American hotel or
it had a connection to Al's bar and we
went to the far ends of the United
States to get it and and after a hundred
and forty nine interviews we really felt
with it we had just a fraction we had
just scratched the surface of all the
wonderful and crazy things that happened
at the American Hotel and the hotel you
know it was built in 1905 and so it's
2019 so do the math it's been over a
hundred years that this hotel has had a
lot of incredible people and we had to
really dig in and go through city
records county records state records
federal census records to uncover who
lived in the hotel and go through oh my
god hundreds I mean hundreds of
different newspapers and well you're
sitting there in the bowels of a library
with microfiche and going over story by
story and you know back in the day
before TV and radio LA had like nine
different newspapers putting out
multiple editions a day mm-hmm so when
something happened at the American Hotel
when there was a stabbing when there was
a shooting when there was a suicide it
made the paper hmm nowadays stabbing or
shooting it's got to be really
spectacular
yeah otherwise it's just a little blurb
online and then it yeah I've gotten yeah
so in the tales in the American is
available on Amazon Prime all right it
is in all digital platforms iTunes are
there some standout characters from well
there's characters that made the movie
and characters that didn't oh really
yeah there's a lot of characters that
I've you tell me a little bit about
either one of those well I'm gonna tell
you about one character named Michael
Gonzalez Michael Michael was a kind of
unique character in that he he was for
his time he was kind of a wild man and
he lived in the hotel and he lived in
other places around the hotel and
Michael uh Michael when he was living in
the hotel would do a lot of crazy things
and we touch upon him in the movie tales
that the American but one of the stories
I can tell you is that one day Michael
on the fourth floor of the hotel you
know he had his shirt off and he grabbed
one of those fire hoses that's on a big
spiral a fight of coiled up fire hose
and he took the nozzle end and wrapped
it around his waist and then proceeded
to pull it not only he's proceeded to
unreal it and go through his room and
out his window and jump down with it
unfurling oh no the problem was he
didn't measure and when he got just
about ten feet off the ground is when it
that was the end of the firehose and so
he jerked up and the fire hose ripped up
the side of his skin and you know how
thick there there's like a credibly
thick rough canvas fire hose and it just
tore up the side of him and but he was
kind of fearless and doing stuff like
that so he survived he survived that
yeah he survived that but
you know and strangely enough he and I
got along great one of the sides that
was his darker side was he was also
sometimes on heroin and so every once in
a while I would come up into the hotel
and I would hear what sounded like the
brain of a donkey and I would I would
realize that's Michael and one time I
came up and I heard this I heard this
brain and he was outside his door on
line up lying on the ground outside his
door with his room key in his hand
trying to get into the keyhole and he
was so messed up on heroin that he just
couldn't get the key into the hole I had
to let him in but so he he was quite a
character in that way Mike Michael you
know he he's no longer with us but and
it's not due to one of the crazy stories
that he's no longer with us
mm-hmm but we had a lot of interesting
characters and another interesting
character I'll tell you about there was
two of them one was named and he lived
at the end of this street
he lived in a concrete little concrete
building at the end of Hunter Street and
it was a wild and wooly placed down
there back in the 80s and early 90s and
there was a guy named Steve wheat I'm
gonna call him Steve wheat wheat does a
interesting last name yeah yeah and
there was another guy named Al and they
both had a really happenin place down at
the end of the street lots of art
exhibitions lots of openings and
apparently Steve wheat had a girlfriend
and no no not Steve al had a girlfriend
and apparently I guess the girlfriend
decided that she now wanted to be with
Steve wheat
now owl is the kind of guy that takes
things into his own hands when he feels
like he's being taken advantage of oh
and one day when Steve wheat and the
girlfriend were gone somewhere else
al took a sawzall and put on a big long
metal cutting blade and proceeded to go
to the middle of Steve's car and saw the
car in half
Wow I mean he went through the roof that
was the easy part the side door panels
but he got it up on blocks and he went
through the chassis and the driveshaft
and everything and when we got back he
knew who had done it
somebody I was so pissed off he cut
Steve's car in half kind of a symbolic
gesture I'd say yeah it's like the kind
of thing we can go to the doctor get
like your hand reattached if it gets cut
off I can go to the mechanic and having
like reattach the two halves of your car
and so that was that was the that was
this yeah I don't think they they
weren't friends after that
no I yeah that would be a bit of a
Alberta took it personally well I would
too if I got my car cut in half by Sam
yeah
it was he was you know Al was really
pissed was it a nice car well it
certainly wasn't after yeah so that was
that was the kind of things that even
happened on hunter Street those here on
Hunter Street right here 150 feet from
where we're sitting a me already on the
building then yes so you're just kind of
watching all this play oh yeah oh yeah
yep yeah you don't want to get between a
man and angry man in us and his saws all
right now it's kind of like a chainsaw
but that that that was quite a quite an
event so there were characters like that
and I remember as I mentioned before we
used to be able to get away with a lot
of things you
can't get away with now and a lot most
of its innocent most no button we you
know it didn't hurt people there were
used to be a series of car dealerships
on Figueroa and you would drive down and
as you passed a car dealership you would
see like a giant balloon oh it has
advertising so you're talking about
characters now you're talking about
yourself as a character right Oh
is your character too right Steve well
sometimes but you could also see
balloons for giant gorillas or balloons
for all sorts of weird inflatable
balloons that are 50 feet by a hundred
feet that are floating above the car
dealership to get people's attention and
one evening my girlfriend and I were
driving down Figueroa and we saw this
giant balloon and it had like a little
gondola basket on it and it was attached
to this car dealership and I looked
around and it was pretty late at night
and I didn't see any police and I didn't
send nobody the dealership was closed
and I climbed up a telephone pole and in
true gorilla fashion I undid the entire
apparatus and dropped a rope down and
came down with the balloon oh and we
attached it to my my VW how big was this
balloon ah 30 by 30 feet yeah whoa like
could you like jump extra high he held
on oh oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah it was
filled with it was a huge it was filled
with helium okay it wasn't no it looked
like a hot air balloon but it was
actually just filled with helium and so
we slowly drove it all the way back to
the arts district to the corner of
Hewitt and traction and we knew that a
lot of our friends would be an Al's bar
and on the way there we had to pull the
balloon down to get under power lines
but we got the balloon back to you and
trash and walked it over to the
intersection there
and right there on the corner where the
American hotel is people came out of the
bar we had a big party
we tied flares we I asked people to go
to their cars to get road flares and we
tied them on and duct-taped them on that
we'd lift them all and we let the
balloon rise up and it was just we had
fun and you know at another start of the
sky huh yeah it was great we watched it
Tilikum the flares completely
disappeared and the balloon disappeared
we don't know if they landed in some
very dry field and said hold on fire we
don't know if they landed in the
suburban neighborhood they whatever it
was the prevailing winds probably took
the balloon out to sea and it without
hurting anybody just went out like two
UFO sightings that night yeah yeah it
was and so you know we had things like
that and we had other people like who's
this now I'm still alive but but there
was another person that lived in the
American hotel his name was big al big
al watt and he was kind of a he was
really wild and crazy guy and he would
go up on top of the American Hotel and
he would shoot off skyrockets skyrockets
yeah he's my rocket well it's kind of
like you know a rocket with a dry
propellant like an engine that's you
know it's a it's like a model rocket
kind of like model but it was it was I
guess it's like a large three foot two
foot long two with a big stick coming
out of the bottom of it and you light it
and it has a nose cone and it would he
would shoot them off and roman candles
and and he'd and he would also do
something else he would start a few
years ago before he died
he would see the neighborhood starting
to gentrify and he would see people
sitting across at a cafe and he would
quietly go back and he would take an
m-80 and they these were big yeah are
they like a quarter-stick of dynamite or
something like that
they sound like it in the urban legend
he would well whatever it is an m-80
makes a lot of noise and he even had one
were big like three-inch long tubes and
he would light them and then chuck them
out right into the street nearby where
people were sitting and drinking their
$4 lattes and $4 yeah that's cheap $4
lattes yeah and he would then just start
laughing like crazy but it sounded like
world war
it sounded like mortars incoming and he
would just pull pranks like that and
sadly he's no longer with us either
that's one way to try to keep the rent
more affordable in the neighborhood yeah
yeah he he didn't like the changes in
the neighborhood but we had characters
like him we also had we had Alberto
Alberto me Aras who is in the movie
tales of the American and Alberto was
and he still is he's a wonderful artist
he makes installations make sculptures
he welds he made what's called the
flame-throwing espresso rod and it
looked sort of like a firetruck isn't
like a hot rod but espresso rod yeah
it's like a truck that looks sort of
like a fire truck and then he on top of
it with a hook and ladder with a ladder
would be he had a setup with a chair and
an espresso machine and underneath it
would have a big canister of gas and it
would shoot out a 20-foot flame Wow so
instead of like Alberto says instead of
putting out fires it would start fire
and he would drive it around for one
event he drove it around in the Arts
District and I was lucky enough to be
there on that that night and actually
photograph him doing that and making
espresso for the crowds of people Wow
yeah it was it was pretty incredible
that's what I'm going to keep your
coffee warm yeah he he he did and he
rode around with a fire fire hat on and
you couldn't do it anymore these days in
that neighborhood art no it you couldn't
do we did a lot of things again we would
go out into the neighborhood wind
Jones died the community got together
and they sort of collectively just had a
giant bonfire in the middle of the
street with chairs and Christmas trees
and and stuff and it was like a Arts
District Burning Man that was the
spontaneous thing that happened and then
the fire went out but nowadays if you
were to do that you'd have 35 people
calling the police the fire department
and you now have guys that are riding
around on bicycles with little purple
helmets and little purple safety vests
safety vests on and they've got
walkie-talkies and if they see somebody
even on a street corner selling scarves
without a permit they immediately forced
them to move on or call the police if
they see a homeless person spending a
little too long on a corner talking with
somebody or possibly asking people for
some change they physically move them on
hmm you know I call that fluff and fold
it's where you fluff and fold
yeah it's a term that the LAPD uses when
you have a problem in an area and you
can't really do anything about the
problem because it's a big social
problem
so they fluff it and fold it and move it
to another area huh
fluff and fold like your bedsheets just
like that and you know these these guys
on the bicycles that work for the
Business Improvement District you know I
mean they just all the spontaneity is
gone you know so are you are you sad to
see the neighborhood change like that
absolutely absolutely it's just and I
think you'll live long enough to see the
changes too I mean I've been here 10
years now I have my ten year anniversary
in December first well then then you are
okay I must officially say that Nikko P
Ranger is a lifer when you've hit ten
years in downtown
that's a life sentence yeah yeah you
could even move to a house nearby and
Highland Park Lincoln Heights
you're still a lifer you've you've done
you've done us you've done yours your
stretch of time in downtown I appreciate
that
yeah I got that badge of honor now man I
mean I've seen big changes too you know
right from the American Apparel
warehouse down the street now being
bought I think by Google and it's been
like renovated for the past two years
and like the Soho House like being built
like right next door to it and of course
across the street is like a textile
factory and across the street from that
is the playpen a fully nude strip club
so it's a weird mashup you know but it's
changing you want to keep the playpen
there I think so yeah you definitely
because the playpen and some of these
other clubs still keep an edge to what
the neighborhood was you know you know I
mean I've never been in the playpen but
any you know but if you checked out that
billboard you can't but help not check
out the billboard beside the street
every time you drive by and and that's
the sign of a healthy neighborhood you
know I mean it used to be back in the
day that certain streets like where
church and state is on Mateo and
industrial and little bear there's
there's the those restaurants that are
there well that used to be one of the
most it was a grungy street it was magic
it was hooker Central and there would be
a lot of truckers with the hookers right
there on industrial street it was that
was ground zero for for for that kind of
business and now it's very very sedate
and it's very different and and so
sometimes things can be better that way
because there's less crime there's you
know but there's still nowadays I would
have to say in the last 20 years the
homeless population the homeless
situation has gotten much much worse
really oh oh yes there's no question
about it how would you try I mean I know
this is a huge huge like topic but how
would you try to address that situation
Wow that is it that's a multiple you'd
have to attack that problem from
multiple situations but affordability of
living space is what's required if I had
if I won the lotto if I won the lottery
and 120 million dollars the first thing
I would do would be to the first thing I
would do if I could buy a couple of
hotels I would buy a couple of hotels
I would retrofit these and I would have
these hotels double rooms single rooms
whatever and I would make sure that they
were rented out to artists to poets to
writers to videographers to filmmakers I
would make sure that on the ground floor
there was affordable eating places
affordable places where artists could
exhibit their work or show their work I
would make it so that and I what I mean
affordable is I'm talking about like 600
700 dollars a month
first for studio space affordable where
an artist is not constantly scrambling
to make rent for of a small small tiny
studio you know you've got rooms that
are 500 400 square foot rooms that you
can you know something again something
so you have that eclectic mix of where
you could go to a poetry reading in a in
a bookshop go to a bar and have a beer
and see a couple of new bands that are
emerging go next door to a gallery maybe
go to a makeshift place where you could
show present some work some new video
work have that environment that's what I
would do mm-hmm I I would want to buy a
whole bunch of buildings
like that and keep it artificially keep
it low as long as I possibly could
hmm and just say hey we've got room for
people that are creative so I mean
everybody in this room if if we had that
opportunity and it was you know
available we would do it and that's that
is affordability now let's say you're
not an artist let's say you're just some
guy that wants to work as a barista more
as a bartender
they still need affordability I mean
they really need affordability because
those are the guys that are serving you
your coffee those are the guys that are
actually preparing you the bacon and
eggs and you know and they've got it
they can't be driving from Rancho
Cucamonga or San Bernardino to come here
to do that yeah they've got to be living
in our community I think the laws need
to specifically state that if an if a
person is going to develop a building
they need to give up a significant
percentage ten percent minimum to people
with incomes that are lower than the
average income you need to have be able
to have a well I just listed it you need
to have that mm-hmm otherwise you're
you're just you know you don't even
police officers even firefighters need
to feel those kind of service people
they need to live in the community they
protect ya cousin you're connected to it
right and if a police officer lives in
Simi Valley but he's got to drive all
the way to work to Police downtown he
has no connection to it in fact he
probably hates it he hates the commute
in he then hates the environment he's in
and then he hates the commute home and
if he's living down here and he can
actually when he's not being a police
officer walked down the street get a
beer talked to the people talked to see
the art scene as it is that's important
so that it's it's a very complex
question but the bottom line is
affordability
hmm I mean for for a quick answer that
was a pretty good answer I thought you
got to be able to live and you got to be
able to eat at reasonable prices it's
like one of the places that I talked
about we were just talking about it the
other day was Philippe's Felipe's up on
North Main I mean you can go in there
and you can still get a cup of coffee
for 47 cents and damn it's coffee you
know boy is it coffee yeah 47 cents and
a refill is unfortunately 47 cents yeah
so well you know that was lot of really
interesting stories and interesting
perspectives on things and I think it's
really cool that you you maintain your
maintain your principles and your ethics
and your ethos with what you do in life
and I feel like that leads to a happier
life because there's a point where you
can take your time and your efforts and
you can put that towards money you can
try to make more income with that but at
a certain point where happiness doesn't
come from that and it comes from doing
the things that you think are important
and I feel like I've a lot of different
people I've met I feel like you're one
of the people that have made that a
priority in their life to pursue the
things that are important to them and I
think it shows in in the passion for the
things that you do and the happiness
that you have with the things that you
do I think in the in the vibrancy that I
guess you approach your life with I mean
at least that's what I for my for my
interactions with you that's what I've
gathered well I I feel that I think
that's a good way to live I felt the
driving force behind doing tales of the
American and interviewing 149 people who
lived there or had a connection to it
was simply this there's a lot of amazing
events that occurred in that hotel both
in my life and in lots of other people's
lives whether it was the
african-american people that lived there
in that hotel first and the Japanese
people that live there and made a life
and then were yanked out because of a
racist decision to
to tear away their their homes and their
businesses and put them in concentration
camps to the artists that moved there
and made paintings and drawings and
music and I felt that if there was not
someone there to actually put their
stories down all of those stories would
disappear like Rutger Hauer says in that
last scene in Blade Runner they would
just disappear like tears in rain and
that's a fact if you don't capture those
stories and put them together it's all
hearsay
and then when I die and you die and then
the stories disappear and I'm sure that
this is nothing unusual I'm sure there's
been billions literally billions of
interesting stories but they've if they
haven't been captured and painted and
recorded on film or are in a song
they're gone mm-hmm and no one has an
opportunity to see those stories or hear
them and you know it wasn't like believe
me we didn't think we were gonna make a
pile of money by doing a documentary and
we haven't but we have a got we have got
a lot of exposure and a lot of people in
fact there's an upcoming show that is
being organized right now by a professor
an art professor named Tom O'Day up in
Spokane College and he's putting
together an exhibition called tales of
the American and it will show actually
it will show clips that will show the
movie constantly and it will have a lot
of art in the gallery from artists that
lived in the hotel and music from
musicians and they're doing a whole book
catalog on on the movie and the
exhibition itself so it will live on and
I think that's what's important one of
the other things that occurred downtown
was a series of events that myself and a
few other people put on together we got
together and we did
sited in around 1990 to have a show
called the red zone that's ya know what
the red zone was was we decided to you
know we don't need no stinkin permits we
don't need to ask permission and we
didn't in the first red zone was
directly across the street of the
American Hotel and it was the building
that is now called versed cuca which is
a sausage and beer place well back in
the day back in the day that was a hotel
and it was called the Keystone hotel and
it was multi-storied and a couple of the
floors burned down and they literally
tore down those stories and the ground
floor is still the bottom of the
Keystone Hotel and for many years a
printer occupied that ground floor with
big printing presses and machines and
when we were be sitting over there
having a beer over at the American we'd
look over and every Friday the guy the
little old man that ran the printing
shop would get in his car and drive off
and go home and not return till Monday
morning and so around this time we said
let's do the first red zone right up
against his whole building so on a
Friday we watched for that little man to
get into his car he locked up his door
got in and drove off and then all of us
about 10 or 15 people got together with
big five-gallon buckets of red paint
fire-engine bright red paint and with
rollers in hand we painted his entire
building from the ground to the rooftop
on all sides bright red and we had a big
stencil that was made that said red zone
art above the law and myself I did an
artwork where I had a I had a silhouette
of myself made of meat that I used
concrete nails and I made a silhouette
of myself in meat on the wall
skip Arnold completely naked wrapped
himself in saran wrap around a nearby
telephone pole other artists hung
paintings
Liz Young whose the sculptor she is
still making work in Los Angeles she
decided to tar and feather
herself and put herself in a cage on the
sidewalk other people did performances
we went around and we did posters all
around the entire Arts District for this
show we took trash cans filled them with
ice loaded them with cases of beer and
gave away beer you can have a really
popular place when you give away beer
and we had roughly by the end of the
evening we had well not by the end of
the by about nine o'clock at night we
had 2,000 people and it was so
incredible the opening was so incredible
that councilman Mike woo showed up and
he loved it he came up and talked to me
and he talked to everybody and he went
wow this is really great and I'm glad he
was there because then the police showed
up
many many police cars showed up and they
wanted to know who's who's putting this
show on and I just they came up to me
and I said oh I don't know he's over
there he know he's over there I think
and and I did not want to be pegged as
the organizer of the red zones and they
would just say well who's running this
and I would go I don't know I think the
guys over there you know there was two
thousand people but Mike will put it
into it he said no this is really great
everything is fine and by that time by
the time the police arrived most of the
beer had been consumed but still there
wasn't an amazing amount of people they
had a great time and we would do things
like that we would just take over a
place and no permission no permits no
porta-potties it had to go to the
bathroom we'd better find an alcove or
somebody studio or something but we
didn't do any of that nonsense that
everybody has to oh and take out a big
insurance policy you know to cover it a
liability policy which is what they want
yeah we didn't do that and we had seven
red zones it's seven seven Wow
we would just go to a building and open
it up that was abandoned and just we
would go to the railroad tracks right
with a railroad
you know the parking space is underneath
the 4th Street bridge so we that's what
it was like hmm
and so those were the red zones and
that's the kind of way it was that and
modern Wild West yeah it was you know it
and was a lot of fun well Steve you're
always filled with awesome stories and
crazy experiences and I appreciate you
coming here to share with everybody and
tell us a little bit about what makes
you you and what makes this part of Los
Angeles what it is you know why we are
able to do what we do here at corridor
digital is in part due to the
environment you the environment that
you've helped create for us and I feel
like a lot of our just get out there and
do it attitude with our video shooting I
think mirrors a lot of the experiences
you've had with your artwork that you've
done as well so thank you again for
appearing on the corridor cast and just
a reminder to everybody tales of the
American is on amazon prime as is young
turks go ahead and go check it out it's
an excellent documentary I vouch for it
myself
and yeah is there any any parting
message you want to give to all the
artists and filmmakers out there trying
to make it happen yeah
just keep you know push the envelope try
something you haven't done before tripe
you know material that's funny try
material that's dark try to be
entertaining but at the same time make
them think about what they're looking at
and the environment that that we live in
cool great well thank you so much Steve
I appreciate it thank you alright that
concludes our podcast here with Stephen
C Meyer the landlord the artist the
filmmaker the crazy guy that tells us
all these cool stories and knows a lot
of cool people if you guys aren't
subscribed to the corridor cast channel
on YouTube please consider doing so we
have a lot of cool experts that we post
from our podcast as well as video
portions that accompany the audio if
you're lessly on other platforms that's
really awesome too so I appreciate all
of you guys listening I stay tuned
because I got more crazy guests on the
way 20:19 is gonna be a good year with
some good content
all right so long everybody